yo someone just set the record for the  longest consecutive spaghetti sick check  it out dude get the [ __ ] out of here  dude it's 90 inches is the pasta  handmade huh  there's no scale that is not a spaghetti  you should put a spoon next to it some  kind of [ __ ] [ __ ] parasite guys  can we just be happy how come there's no  marinery there's a little bit right  there about to give them some other  information Ryan's going to be like yeah  this just came out of a urethra  all of you spaghetti haters  this is a handle list jump rope that a  man was able to stuff completely in his  Eureka oh that it's a 79 year old man  took the handles off of a jump rope  stuffed the entire 90 inches of jump  rope into his urine wait they had to cut  his bladder open kids you got to quit  the porn now this guy's like I can't  even nut unless I removed  it's a Japanese guy so you know his  urethra is small oh you're right who has  the biggest urethroughs again Congolese